The New York Times ran a story
about how the Trump
administration is doing,
and it's dark!
Literally.
Trump aides are reportedly so
unfamiliar with the White House
that they have meetings
in the dark
because they can't find
the light switches.
-(laughter)
-Even sad...
Even sadder-- Trump apparently
splits his time
between sitting around
in his bathrobe watching TV
and giving inaccurate tours
of the Oval Office.
He told one visitor
that the office's golden drapes
were used by FDR, but they were
actually made for Bill Clinton.
And that should be
really easy to remember,
'cause they threw out
all the White House fabrics
-after Clinton.
-(laughter)
-Got rid of 'em.
-Oh! -Ugh!
It's like, "Get out.
Just burn these.
-Just burn these."
-Ugh! -(applause)
Burn these.
Of course, Trump said the
article was just lies, tweeting,
"The failing @nytimes writes
total fiction concerning me.
"They have gotten it wrong
for two years,
and now they're making up
stories and sources!"
And then he went back
to watching Fox News
-on a TV George Washington
built. -(laughter)
So, comedians, what are some
other fake White House facts
Donald Trump tells his tours?
Ron Funches.
All the water fountains
are whites only.
-HARDWICK: All right.
-(laughter and groaning)
-(cheers and applause)
-PUDI: Yeah!
-Yeah!
-HARDWICK: Points.
Mr. Alan Tudyk.
The Lincoln bedroom is named
after our greatest president,
-President Bedroom.
-Yeah!
HARDWICK:
Yes. Very good. Points.
-(cheers and applause)
-HARDWICK: But that one's true.
-I think that one's true.
-Fact. -That one is true.